ich habe ja als erster bereits am
freitag haben gesagt es spricht hier
einiges dafür dass es sich um
islamistischen terror handeln könnte
aber natürlich muss das alles sorgfältig
ermittelt werden
ja es gibt diesen hinweis der täter hat
wohl im laufe der folgenden stunden dann
wohl auch mal davon gesprochen dass
handelt es sich um seinen beitrag zum
dschihad
die polizei hat ja dann auch sofort
seinen wohnraum in der
obdachlosenunterkunft in der gelebt hat
durchsuchte hat hier auch wohl einiges
gefunden was auf islamistisches
propagandamaterial hinweisen könnte aber
all das geschieht im moment und ich sage
nochmal ja es spricht sehr viel
angesichts dessen was wir auf gefunden
haben dafür dass es sich um eine
islamistische islamistisch motivierte
tat handeln könnte